[Música]
hoje vou falar pra vocês sobre filhos
por favor levante a mão quem tem filhos
quem que têm filhos na faixa dos 2 anos
de idade
essas poucas pessoas vão me entender
eu tenho uma filha de sete meses e um
filho de 2 anos e 7 meses que acha que
tem quatro anos que está na fase dos
porquês e todos os dias é um desafio
tentar explicar para ele responder todas
as perguntas ensiná lo a lidar com seus
sentimentos com as suas frustrações e
com as famosas birras e todos os dias
pequenos contratos são realizados para
que a gente possa convencê lo acordar
tomar banho trocar de roupa se alimentar
e as 7 30 da manhã eu vou no quarto dele
abri a janela e falo e aí é o vamos
acordar bom para a escolinha
ele fala mamãe mamãe eu quero dormir
mais fecha a janela mãe e eu na ânsia de
convencê lo porque eu tenho uma reunião
às 8 30 eu falo meu filho vamos nós
vamos passear vamos trocar de roupa nós
vamos passear na verdade não vamos nós
vamos para a escolinha que tipo de
mensagem estou passando para o meu filho
que tipo de vícios estão sendo
construídos nesses pequenos contratos os
relacionamentos familiares são a base
para a construção do nosso caráter dos
nossos valores dos nossos princípios e é
onde se iniciam esses pequenos contratos
que posteriormente se estenderam para o
ambiente escolar para as amizades para o
trabalho para o relacionamento amoroso
para as ações de associativismo entre
outros
diariamente todos nós realizamos
diversos pequenos contratos cada um de
nós em nossa própria realidade
nós estamos negociando tempo todo pra
alcançar os nossos interesses
por isso eu gostaria de pedir para vocês
abra uma breve reflexão
como vocês estão agindo para atingir os
seus objetivos
vocês estão respeitando os seus valores
vocês estão sendo integrados como é a
sua postura do seu comportamento como
cidadão
cada um desses pequenos contratos que
nós realizamos diariamente é um acordo
de vontade entre duas ou mais partes e
quando nós transportamos isso para o
ambiente político empresarial
nós verificamos que não só os políticos
são corruptos
verificamos que se não houver empresário
disposto a entrar no esquema
a roda não gira o sistema não funciona
e quando a gente fala de corrupção a
gente fala de pequenos e grandes
contratos ilegais e antiéticos que vão
favorecer um pequeno grupo e aí a gente
se pergunta mas o que eu posso fazer
para mudar essa realidade
hoje muitas empresas possuem programa de
comprar complexa estruturado que visam
instruir os seus funcionários sobre o
que é ética quais são os valores e os
princípios da empresa através de
treinamentos elaboração de um código de
conduta
o manual do colaborador políticas
internas procedimentos e outros nomes
que as empresas dão internamente o grupo
de trabalho de integridade com pães do
b20 que é um grupo da sociedade civil
que trabalha para apresentar propostas
de políticas públicas para os governos
dos países que compõem o g20 do qual faz
parte
agora neste ano de 2018 elaborou um
relatório que recomenda que os governos
levem esta realidade de programa de
companhais para esfera pública através
da implementação desses programas
completos nas empresas está estatais e
da exigência de programas de compliance
para as empresas privadas que têm o
interesse de contratar com o governo
um dos setores que está mais envolvido
em escândalos de corrupção
brasil e no mundo é o setor de
infraestrutura
por isso o b20 recomenda que sejam
reforçados os critérios de integridade e
transparência nesses contratos públicos
a fim de reduzir a sua utilidade à
corrupção o b20 acredita que para as
empresas e para os governos conseguirem
atingir esse objetivo eles devem
estabelecer uma critérios padronizados
para essas empresas privadas que queiram
contratar obras de infraestrutura em
infraestrutura pública com o governo
elas devem promover justiça
transparência e prestação de contas
aberta em todo o ciclo do contrato de
obras públicas e que eles devam
construir cooperação e alinhamento
estratégico entre os governos entre a
parte pública ea parte privada no que
tange a segunda recomendação que eu
comentei que é sobre implantar é
programas de compliance nas empresas
estatais a fim de reduzir a corrupção
essas empresas estatais elas devem
aderir aos mais altos padrões de
integridade e de conformidade
de acordo com as boas práticas
internacionais que os seus stakeholders
devem assumir o compromisso de divulgar
todos os relatórios dos programas anti
corrupção e que haja promoção ea
facilitação de ações coletivas de
complexa entre os setores públicos e os
setores privado
essas ações que são recomendados pelo de
20 promovem uma um melhor ambiente de
negócios e também uma mudança cultural
tanto no setor público quanto no setor
privado em um ambiente de negócio mais
ético mais transparente e atrair
investimentos
ele atrai investimento principalmente
investimento estrangeiro promove a
geração de emprego o aumento da renda da
população eo desenvolvimento regional
e esse deve ser o caminho nós estamos
passando por uma mudança cultural a
nível global padrões de comportamentos
que antes eram aceitos
hoje não sou mais aceitando e eu falo em
padrões de comportamento porque são
atitudes institucionalizadas e já
tolerados há muitos anos por todos os
entes da sociedade governo e iniciativa
privada sociedade de forma geral segundo
estudo do fundo monetário internacional
o fmi publicado em dezembro de 2016 2%
do produto interno bruto mundial que é
algo em torno de 1.5 a 2 trilhões de
dólares são gastos anualmente com o
pagamento de propina que é um dos
aspectos da corrupção
estudo realizado este ano pela é o imã
trouxe barometer revelou que 20 dos 28
países analisados estão na categoria de
falta de confiança em suas instituições
a sociedade brasileira está exigindo uma
mudança cultural
só esse ano nós pagamos mais de 2
trilhões de reais em impostos até hoje e
com todos nós sabemos estes recursos não
voltam pra gente em forma de serviços
públicos de qualidade
o estudo o ibope realizou um estudo no
final do ano passado e nesse estudo esse
estudo revelou que pela primeira vez na
história do brasil
a maior preocupação de 62% dos eleitores
para essa eleição de 2018 era a
corrupção
eu gostaria que a gente fizesse um
pequeno exercício
nós estamos em 2018 vamos voltar em 2013
cinco anos atrás se alguém virá se para
você em 2013 falar assim 2018 nós vamos
ter um ex-presidente da república preso
o que você diria nós vamos ter um dos
principais empresários grandes
empresários brasileiros vai passar
alguns poucos natais na cadeia e vai
usar uma pequena uma pequena adereço na
sua casa como você reagiria que a
petrobras iria pleitear na justiça
mais 40 bilhões
a título de multa e indenização em 16
ações de improbidade administrativa a
fim de se ressarcir de atos de corrupção
e fraude que vocês falarem com essa
pessoa
eu simplesmente não acreditaria na
frente da tv
nós acompanhamos o processo de
impeachment presidencial
nós acompanhamos as ações de busca e
apreensão da polícia federal
nós acompanhamos os julgamentos da lava
jato e do stf
fatos que muitas vezes nos assustam e
que nos apresentam uma nova realidade
uma nova forma de ver essa realidade
está provocando uma mudança cultural e
na frente dessa mesma tv eu tenho que
fazer pequenos contratos com meu filho
pra gente negociar que nós vamos qual
música nós vamos cantar e dançar juntos
que não pode comer assistindo televisão
porque tem que prestar atenção no
alimento que nós temos horário para
desligar a televisão e que amanhã o
balão mágico ea galinha pintadinha
estarão esperando pra gente poder
brincar mais
quando nós estamos em família os nossos
pequenos contratos eles são feitos com
base no amor com base na confiança
quando a gente está em sociedade os
nossos pequenos com contratos são feitos
com base no respeito respeito às leis de
trânsito respeito aos assentos
prioritários de idosos gestantes e
deficientes e respeito aos nossos amigos
e quando a gente vai para o campo
empresarial não pode ser diferente
os nossos valores nossos princípios deve
nos acompanhar no ambiente profissional
também e cada vez mais nós precisamos
nos reconectar com os nossos sentimentos
com os nossos valores porque nós
precisamos de sabedoria para poder agir
com coragem
todo mundo sabe a importância do exemplo
em nossas vidas
nossas empresas nós como líderes
as nossas palavras
sonhos reações influi diretamente nas
pessoas com as quais trabalhamos na
sociedade o nosso comportamento afeta o
ambiente estamos inseridos e o bom
convívio social
e quando estamos em família nós somos
exemplos para os nossos filhos
nós influenciamos o seu crescimento o
seu desenvolvimento ea formação do seu
caráter
cada vez mais fica claro para a gente a
importância do nosso papel social nesses
pequenos contrato que nós realizamos
diariamente e destes na mudança cultural
da sociedade que a gente tem um desejo
nós queremos e merecemos viver no brasil
melhor
no brasil mais ético no brasil mais
fraterno um brasil mais justo e
principalmente no brasil mais humano e é
esse brasil que eu quero ajudar a
construir para votar e para os meus
filhos e para os filhos de vocês brigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]